hey Ari so first I want to get your
reaction here to the breaking news of
the night Colorado Supreme Court of
course saying Trump you're off the
ballot an obscure legal Theory we had
Jonathan turle on he laid that all out
for
us it it's an Abomination it's an
Abomination from a legal point of view
and mostly from a moral point of view
what about the people of Colorado don't
they have a right to vote for the
candidate of their choice what about all
the down ballot candidates in Colorado
who are going to be affected as a result
of if it went through not having Donald
Trump at the top of the ticket these
things are just power plays designed to
be anti-democratic and I I cannot stand
it because when one party does it the
other party will do it and they keep
breaking the norms and Republicans match
but the Democrats keep breaking the
Norms
first that's right and it is a quite a
norm to be broken saying you know
president Trump we're going to put you
in the same camp as two Confederates and
use this 14th Amendment section three
Mark Penn coming to you on this report
on the president's age I I think it's
highly unusual for a first lady to be
that involved in scheduling perhaps it
was overblown who knows but that is the
report the report we know is true is
that when you look at the polling AP o
RC
77% of Americans say Biden is too old to
be president and that includes
69% of Democrats how are you guys going
to turn that
around well look my polls too show that
age is a real concern but hey I I am
used to first ladies having something to
say about the schedule so I don't think
that's much of a news story and look I
thought the good news in the report was
that President Biden was ready to get
out there and wanted to go campaign and
that the AIDS were holding him back
that's a much better story than the
reverse when the AIDS want to get him
out here and he says I'm too tired and I
can't do it so I'm not so sure that
wasn't even planted as a story that hey
he can't wait to get out there there and
defeat Donald
Trump you know Tommy I mean it's a fair
point people plant stories in order to
get a narrative out there and the
narrative certainly was you know Biden
wants to do more than what his AIDS are
allowing him to do but the story also
says AIDS are rolling their eyes Joe
Biden's having to stop him from getting
out on the campaign Trail there's a
vicious cycle we all see play out your
thoughts about Joe Biden controlling
Biden's
schedule well I certainly didn't vote
for Joe Biden but I don't think anybody
voted for Jill Biden and I'll say this
it's nice to see that she's showing some
concern about her husband any wife no
matter what side of the political aisle
you sit on should show concern for their
spouse for their husband but she should
show the same concern and if she feels
like he can't do the job she should ask
him not to do the job she should ask him
not to run for reelection if she's
really so concerned she shouldn't be
putting him up to this task not only for
his health but for the health of our
nation and as far as this being a
planted story that he's rearing to go
and AIDS are saying that maybe he should
rest either way you spin that story it
doesn't look good because it means that
his AIDS are not confident in his
ability to speak his ability to perform
you see them white knuckling it every
time he's allowed to go off prompter
even when he is using the prompter
they're terrified of what he might say
they're also terrified of what Hunter
might say so at this point everybody
just wants Joe to go back to the
basement including Jill and that doesn't
well for him certainly not for his poll
numbers when KLA Harris is creeping up
on you you know you've got a real
problem at
home yeah you do Ari you know you and I
were both White House Press secretaries
and you know how journalism works
there's these Anonymous sources they run
with stories and there were a lot of
leaks during the Trump era but there
were very few leaks I would argue in the
very beginning of the Biden era they
seem to have their staff under control
in that regard but lately
look at these headlines all these
headlines of AIDS who might see the bad
polling for President Biden Biden's
reluctant to accept his old age AIDS say
Biden said to be increasingly frustrated
by dis dismal poll numbers that was AIDS
again emotions are running high at the
White House as some AIDS report
frustration with Israel is growing is
there this correlation between poll
numbers down AIDS
leaking yeah there always is because
people just don't want to take the blame
themselves so they're going to leak and
say somebody else deserves the blame if
only people listened to me that's a
story what happens but you know the the
leak about the staffers who oppose the
president's policy on Israel who
cares they're staffers they are not the
elected official their position is
immaterial you're priv privileged to be
in the Oval Office to be in the white
house you can give your advice and if
your advice isn't listened to that's the
way it is
and for them to squawk about it is just
absolutely out of bounds I'm kind of
shocked that anybody in the White House
any staffer would think so much of
themselves that they would do that as
the president's age Kaylee I I I will
say we all know 80y olds and God bless
them if they think they can go out and
play golf that they're healthier that
they can do things that they used to do
when they're younger you want that
attitude in an 80-year-old but not when
they're the president of the United
States presidents of the United States
who were that age who think they still
have their down put the country at risk
and that's what happens that was
increasingly what will happen when you
have a 81 82 83 84 year old president if
Joe Biden stays in this race if he gets
reelected you know Mark one piece of
reporting I picked up on it was that it
was last year and I'm curious it gets to
the interaction between Biden's age and
his campaign strategy and we know he
stayed in the basement last campaign uh
there was one debate that that didn't
happen and that was because of Co at the
time president Trump had covid but
what's interesting is that may be a
strategy they intend to repeat check
this out this is from Politico senior
Democrats private take on Biden he's too
old the Biden folks believe Trump or any
other Republican nominee will be
reluctant to work with the commission on
presidential debates lessening the
chances and risk of a head-to-head
debate is Biden scared to
debate well I I certainly am very Pro
debate so I I really think it would be
terrible for the country if there
weren't presidential debates I mean look
it seems to be a pattern the less we see
of Donald Trump the better he does in
his polls the more we see of President
Biden the more trouble he has with his
polls so between these two I don't know
whether they can get together and hold a
debate it sure would be good for the
country if we had presidential debates
because I think that's what America
really needs to see and since Kennedy
and Nixon it's been a tradition I think
that's been invaluable to
voters no doubt Tommy lren do those
debates
happen I would sure like to say so but
unfortunately with Donald Trump and I
hate to say this but with him not
showing up to any Republican debates it
gives the Democrats an easy out it gives
Joe an easy out to say he's not going to
debate Donald Trump so that's why I
really wish Donald Trump would show up
and debate his Republican opponents I
know he's way ahead in the polls he
shines brightly on a debate stage so
there's no reason for him not to engage
we know he loves to talk he loves to
talk to the American people he needs to
show up if none other reason that he
needs to not give Joe that out we need
to hear from our presidential candidates
no matter how old or young they are we
need to see them on the stage we need to
see them debating I certainly hope to
see it but don't give Joe the out Donald
Trump please show up and show them what
you've
got and we have seen I I believe Clinton
folks who works for the campaign the
Biden campaign cite that rationale that
you just do you think Joe Biden's the
nominee do you think Joe Biden shows up
at the
debates uh no way on the debates I
cannot imagine his staff would want him
to show up and I don't think he's going
to do it um that was a trend that
started in a lot of gorial and Senate
races it's going to extend to the
presidency this year
unfortunately um and then as as far as
my prediction Kaye I'm where I've always
been I give it a one and three shot that
Joe Biden is forced to drop out right
before the Democratic Convention in
August because the Democrats look around
and say he's a sure loser and we don't
want to go down with his ship and at the
convention they're going to find
somebody else I give that a one and
three
shot wow well it's going to be a wild
year we do not doubt that 2024 here we
come Tommy Ari mark thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else